oh I'm playing taggi okay all do I go
blindfold
I have to go blindfold tigey's be me the
last like so many games it's like Oh
blindfold this will be casual this time
I'm going goody mode in honor of hoodie
guy because AG invader okay how do I do
this
sound okay no mercy this time also I
won't type slip because I'm looking at
the keyboard no mercy okay I'm also
gonna play a London is why not
wait why okay D for D for London time
Bishop f4 yeah it's a good sign when the
pawn starts thinking after Bishop f4
each five Queen each five queen each
five I'm I don't think I mean you
missing anything
maybe talkies playing blind too it was
very generous very generous whoa its
destruction bits
ah wait g6 is attacking my queen do I
play Queen e5 but then at six six is too
scary let's play Queen h4 Queen h4 h4 it
seems reasonably are you serious
I thought nine f6 was played g6 was
played 55 p39 h5 e three Queen h4 Queen
b6 was played okay
I thought g6 was playing
okay I just misheard so it's screen for
Knights okay Knight c3 c3 okay
oh that's traumatic there's no way I'm
losing five minutes late c6 Castle focus
on Bishop b4 should be 492 which means
King b1 mm-hmm Knights and see 603
looking at the keyboard still having
trouble decisions tradition of g3 Bishop
takes g3 age takes g3 huh B 5 B 5 is
scary little twisty free c3 not the type
of chess I want to play but I have to
play defensively the e7 trying to
confuse me metaphor I guess I have a
threat here I think
also have wait where's blots other minor
piece it's on e7 and and cat6 okay
that's a free pawn I believe Bishop
takes b5 Shrek let's play Bishop d3 d3
the void trades rook be it expected v8
yeah King a 1/1 avoiding Queen takes a
three threats played Bishop d7 I believe
Bishop on g7 9 + e 7 v 6 Queen music
threatening me let's play with people be
one sure castle sure castling
interesting oh there's so much going on
on all sides of the board my bishop
signed e3 pawn don't three g4 have to
attack should be 5
I don't trade this is C 2 C 2 okay like
saw on e7 g v g5 want to move I take
that takes g5 okay that's a free thing
my knight and my rook I saw ever work on
each one 236 lets me make each five
nights on g5 h5 I bet my nights my rook
and my bishop are coordinating this this
is looking fun Queen a 6 e 6
not sure what that does it's like f4 get
more stuff into the time three Bishop d3
Wow mmm I don't really want to trade
I have to Bishop takes d3 Queen takes d3
hmm 9h the night pod I got six looking
for the the breakthrough it's easy coos
9h five check white two minutes 12
seconds
black two minutes 27 seconds
kingi eight nine f6 check Chuck King g7
hmm Knight g h7 that's risky but that's
interesting
page eight okay I'm really trying to
attack here my nights are talking to
each other Queen saw and III yeah I do
have Knights I've worked on b1 keeping
me safe III takes III oh dear oh let's
play chief yes
queen bee f11 attacking the Queen I
still have a knight on f6 it's blocking
my queen deed you my stuff 22
22 Jack
I need five I have to play rugby wanna
it's so sad
that's so so sad my time is short - hmm
maybe I should have taken the draw I am
playing for a while or Knight f4
interesting played g6
Jesus to open things up 93 oh man it's
slightly terrifying Wow Jesus oh no it
doesn't work ah this is really I not
have anything aged five nights on d3
okay let's play on rookie f1 white zero
minutes 46 seconds black one minute 26
seconds mmm room takes me to son g6 6
chapter 6 J
not in each seven King takes h77 check
okay kingi six she's six
look at six
kingi five is there plenty six oh no no
no I
there wasn't even a mouse slip I just
thought g6 was playing like this is such
the most natural move so I was
envisioning this position and Coolidge
fourth so natural good game tog II the
thing was like I I thought my attack was
pretty strong like around here and it
seems so close I just didn't see the the
winning idea well plate Auggie